hey guys and welcome to episode 16 of
this Dutch city series this episode is
in a way split up into two main parts or
you could say three first half of this
video is mainly going to be about the
countryside adding a lot more farm
fields around this town and the second
part is going to focus on adding more
details to the town itself and also
moving back to the original city
actually to go back to the old
interchange which was one of the first
things which I ever built in the city
being that dog-bone interchange near the
entrance of the city where I actually
want to downgrade the road to remove the
dog bone and to change and just make it
a simple traffic light interchange and
add a bicycle bridge actually to that
which is an idea that I've been wanting
to try for quite a long time but before
that's there's still a lot of farm
fields that I still need to make over
here and I was really debating whether I
actually wanted to put this into
time-lapses and I've decided to just
sort of go on both so I'll actually
still show the majority of making these
farm fields but since it takes such a
long time to actually make these and
since I am quite sat on trying to make
this entire area look realistic to have
a convincing country side around the
city itself it's really going to take a
lot of time and I don't want to quite
actually use all of that for videos
since it's gonna get quite repetitive
after a while so yes I'll actually get
down the most of this area in this
episode but I'll also do quite a lot of
removing or fine-tuning and/or adding
extra details off screen or even adding
fields at some point so yeah it's the
next cup of episodes I will be working
on a bit of countryside nearly every
single episode simply because it's
something that I don't avoid but it is
quite a time-consuming thing so I don't
want to show it off completely and I'm
trying to at least find a sort of middle
ground there that's you know I can show
it off but still not have it be too much
of the focus of this entire series
anyway I just wanted to finish these
fields over here in much of a similar
way of what I currently have which is
very much inspired by the south of
Holland
and being a it's not an as grid-like
style of farm fields as you see in some
areas and i feel this is something which
i should talk about a little bit more
since i haven't really explained it too
much but there are so many different
types of farm or countryside layouts as
upset in the last episode and i really
want to follow this type since there are
some other types you have the very long
narrow grassy fields with religious
grants where usually cows graze which
you find very much in the center of
holland there are also the very grid
like styles of areas that are only just
very recently reclaimed from the sea or
from lakes which you find in flavor
loans or the beim stir which is very
great like almost this american grid ish
but even the towns in those areas are
nearly completely square shaped and it
is something which i would like to try
in the future as well but definitely not
why i am going to go for in this case
because the style that i want to go for
here is really what i feel works best
for this area and is also most visible
in city skylines as much as i would like
to get in the very stereotypically dutch
type of grassy cow fields as you see
them with very narrow fields and ditches
everywhere it's just really hard to make
it work especially since there aren't
any realistic ditches to do so and since
it's quite hard to actually paint very
small strips of land with the exact
textures that I would like to use for
that type of countryside so yeah really
I'll still be going with the more
agricultural countryside with a layout
switches in a way quite square-ish and
doesn't curve around too much but still
has a bit of a medieval legacy effect
where the land is still quite old and
even though over time you have this
effect where fields sort of converge
because farmers want to exchange fields
to make them more efficient or as they
change over time but still they aren't
completely planned in a way that you
complete grid fields are so yeah that's
the type of fields which I want to make
here but I do think at
some point in the future it would be
nice to actually go into the more
grid-like fields anyway about the
details that I wanted to place over here
I went absolutely mad with the
windbreakers at this point and I think
that's already sort of turned into a
running gag on my live stream but I am
I'm actually going to tone it down on
the windbreakers in the future that's
something which I definitely want to do
and don't get me wrong the windbreakers
are pretty important I do very commonly
see them in the Netherlands basically
they're really long lines of trees which
you use to break the wind and protect
the crops but it's something which you
don't quite see as much as I wanted to
place them over here so that's something
I might want to tone down in the future
also they're really dense the ones that
I've placed so far and I may want to
just make them a little bit less dense
now I think actually these fields over
here which I'm laying down are the best
example of how I think these fields are
grid-like but in a way not completely
since you can quite clearly see that the
dikes are of course not completely
straight and there's a river that river
that is which I really wanted to have
curved around this entire area and just
some places where the road is a bit
crooked but aside from that you try to
like grid your way through that so it's
almost like a limited grid in a sense
that there is a general grid and you can
see a general style of squares over here
but they have to be limited and confine
themselves to the sort of limitations
that the already present curvy roads and
curvy rivers have and I think that's
really quite clear in this specific area
over here where especially that River
really curves around the area and some
of the roads just completely go straight
through the grid but the grid at least
still tries to find its way through that
actually I think I'll actually at some
point in the future remove that bridge
of the highway which yeah I turned that
into a bridge at some point in future
because I was figuring there is no way
that I can actually have a dike and just
because there is a highway which is a
mistake that I didn't make a couple of
times and when it comes to this dike
it is really another example of how some
of the more older still left things like
the dykes are very curvy and unplanned
and it really just Wiggles its way
through the surroundings over here and
the farm fields are as straight as you
can get them pretty much in that area
and when it comes to these sizes of the
farm fields I think I am quite happy
about them there's still a little bit
smaller which is something which I might
want to come back to but I'm really not
sure since it all really also depends on
how I'm gonna place these farms because
from this point onwards this is
something which I haven't done so far
but looking back I it was really a
better idea to start doing this right
from the start which is to actually plan
where farms are going to be so that
every single field or every single
couple fields is going to have one farm
and one house so realistically they are
divided into different plots where
different people own some of the
different plots and where I wanted to
just have a couple of sheds and bones
for some of the different plots as well
and at least make sure that all of the
fields actually look like they belong to
different people and not that the fields
and the houses and other buildings are
just randomly plopped down with no
actual connection between them another
interesting issue over here which I
actually got some comments about is the
fact that I don't actually use the power
lines to get to other cities which is
mainly because even though there are
power lines in the Netherlands they are
so much larger than the ones that come
in city skylines and which really goes
for nearly every country it's one of my
main sort of little pet peeves how small
the power lines actually are in this
game so I decided that I did rather want
to go with the wooden poles the utility
poles which I'm pretty sure come from a
Japanese pack which even though they are
quite uncommon in another lens you see
them sometimes I think they're quite
quite common around Gowda so I really
figured might as well get them in and
use those to at least get the
electricity around since it feels more
natural and realistic than having the
very
small power lines which I wasn't really
happy about and yeah here's where I
really wanted to divide the different
time so you can see that every single
farm which is placed sort of has its own
plots be at a couple fields or be at one
large field I still wanted to make sure
that every farm farm at least connects
to some field in some way Oh actually
did see that just now that I put two
farms in one field oh well that's
something I might want to return to the
future this is actually the first time I
saw that and also wanted to make sure
that alongside the dikes and rivers
especially I still wanted to have quite
a lot of houses which I've gotten some
comments about as well stating that I
might have too many houses for the
countryside but I still want to keep
this quite densely populated and you do
see that in real life as well the
countryside really is quite densely
populated in the Netherlands and
especially around some of these older
dikes you saw you sort of find that over
time they have pretty much gotten houses
around the sides of the road that's
going over the dike which is something
which I really wanted to have over here
as well I mean the houses on the dikes
are quite a signature part of the
landscape as well and one thing to keep
in mind about this by the way is that I
helped back on a couple of tree lines
around this river since the ruined
texture was ridiculously going outside
the river but such an amazing add
addition that came with snow form which
I didn't have when I recorded this
episode yet oh is that the ruined
texture finally doesn't leap over the
rivers too much like over here does the
ruined texture the sand even though
there is still a cliff between the river
and the rest of the land so I still get
all of that sand for some reason but
that's actually been fixed in snowfall
which is really awesome so there will be
less sand in the future which I'm really
happy about which also means that I'll
be able to actually play with trees over
here speaking of those windmills by the
way I wanted to have a couple of
windmills over here but I'm actually
gonna remove them and move them at some
point in the future I think so I'm not
quite sure if I just want to have four
windmills in that location so I'll still
play
with that idea in the future but I
definitely want to have windmills over
here
it's just something which is really one
of those things where I like to just
place them and remove them and place
them and remove them until I really find
that I'm happy with the exact placement
so that's better for off-camera work as
well but yeah just another quick point
which I should mention now that I think
of it I have done quite a bit of
research since I actually lost our first
went into making a countryside next to
the large city and I do feel like I'm at
least improving in it but I'm still very
open to feedback and I don't have that
much real-life experience other than the
area generally where I live and cycle
around in so really if you have some
ideas don't be afraid to shoot them and
I will get back to this area and
fine-tune different things of the city
and especially this countryside in the
future which I may or may not do in an
actual episode I might also do it in a
real-time part since I have been feeling
like it might be better to at least put
some more real-time parts into the
videos but in general I do and I keep it
very time-lapse based but a very reason
that even though I'm not going that much
into detail I am trying to go a lot into
realism and the scale of this is
incredibly huge I think so far it might
not seem like it but I've already
covered around 12 tiles or something
like that and this is already closing in
on the edge of the map
whereas I started in the centre of the
map so yeah this is really large
undertaking and which is why I do want
to not get too much real-time footage in
but I should probably at least have a
bit more real-time looking back and what
I did oh this is so annoying - I really
need to get into that but so many of the
forms I just placed in hopes of getting
some actual foreign buildings which I
likes which I like like silos and things
like that but eventually ended up
getting these weird orange patches where
nothing really grows or some of the or
choose which is especially awkward to
have a oak orchard next to a tree line
when
breaking oak thing it's yeah I got like
so many oak orchards which was awkward
basically because I surrounded all the
arches with Oaks and that was like the
strange thing anyway
I'm actually going back to the second
part of this video I wanted to finish
the detailing of this town since I
didn't move to the northern part of the
town yet and there is obviously still a
lot to be finished around here when it
comes to foliage as well and at least
this'll help actually finishing this
entire town and make it look presentable
for some off-road shots it's still going
to take a long time to actually get to
the countryside around this side of the
town because quite frankly after doing
so many episodes of countryside I do
sort of want to move on to some more
interesting and different things again
but yeah I really wanted to finish this
area especially since this is arguably
the most new area and really one of
those smaller developments which you
commonly see around small towns and I
just kind of like making those
especially the small ring of detached
houses around this town here because
what you find actually is that
especially in recent years more newer
housing developments are increasingly
small-scale and especially in the 70s
and 80s there used to be very large and
huge plant neighborhoods whereas now it
grows a little bit more organically with
very small separate projects and you can
see that especially in smaller towns in
huge cities it doesn't really stick out
that much but in smaller towns you do
sometimes see these very small
neighborhoods just a couple of rows of
houses where some new developments have
been built just to very slowly expand
upon the town which is something which I
wanted to do over here and just for I
guess in a way realism purposes of at
least having some services in this town
but also because I just needed it in the
game to not let this town be a complete
failure I needed to just have this small
hospital and high school and actually
figured I might as well add a small road
service station to it as weird as it
could be at least that makes this into
it almost a very small industry or
park as well and I really needed some
road maintenance over here to prevent
all these roads from crumbling down in
this town regardless this was a lot of
fun to get back to the trees and
actually go a bit overboard with using
different trees over here which granted
is something which I'm very much on the
fence about I really like using many
different trees and adding a lot of
shrubbery to and a lot of detail to the
foliage but the issue with that is just
that it's not so realistic
especially when it comes to three lines
that religious the same tree in a rather
straight line without much ground
shrubbery or foliage and even when it
comes to small patches of trees or
bushes you don't really see that huge of
a variety usually so even though I like
to really go overboard with them at
least for realism sake and I don't go
too crazy with the bushes and trees
which is partly really something which I
mean it's easier to do it without
overdoing the foliage and it takes less
time but it's also a lot of fun to do so
so yeah sometimes I do sort of miss out
on that and just want to overdo my
foliage for a bit but yeah in general I
do wanna keep the foliage quite simple
and not have to new jersey variety or
make it too dense
I really don't want the city to end up
like a jungle especially since there
actually isn't that much forestry in the
Netherlands oh and one small part which
I also wanted to do here was to make a
small square just in front of the
station with some bricks and some
details to at least make this area look
a bit more like a nice entrance to the
town and a good parts to the city centre
it's actually very surprisingly busy
over here and thank God I actually
already have those trains I'm running
into traffic issues because I really
wanted to follow the traffic
realistically as in real life but it's a
lot busier than you would see in real
life so there are already quite some
traffic jams from this town into the
large city but the Train is actually
really helping to relieve that and I
don't even think I ever set this realtor
in a video yet but I will be doing a
real-time bus episode
at some point in the future but at least
at some point in the future when all the
roads are finished and I can actually
get to that so yeah another pointing
with which are at least relieve the
congestion somewhat in the future is by
having some bus lines but yeah this is
pretty much the city center very simple
square didn't really want to do too much
with it but really didn't want to leave
it just empty especially since the road
alongside the railroad over here as you
quite commonly see sort of like the main
street of the town which is if you have
a town which is really built around the
railroad you'll commonly see that the
old core is just around the station and
that the road sort of following it is
the main little road of the town and
then you also have the road which leads
to the church and then you've got the
Station Road in the church Road and
that's pretty much all the core that you
need in general and just as a large part
I just wanted to add some more foliage
to the area of the football fields which
I also got some responses about whether
it's actually true that it's like one
football field per couple thousand
people which I think I actually found
that at some point in the past but I
can't really remember it but yeah it is
definitely something like that anyway
when it comes to downgrading this road I
really wanted to do it since the
dog-bone interchange was there but it
didn't really look like it needed it too
bad and even though this will definitely
lead to more congestion it actually
deals the with the traffic all right as
you can see and I didn't want to run
about this area simply because well it I
don't really need that many roundabouts
over here and you do commonly see that
entrance roads to City have traffic
lights
just because a traffic light interchange
still has a higher capacity than a
regular roundabout but the main point
why I wanted to do this or was because I
wanted to try the idea of a bicycle
bridge and bicycle bridges are very
common in the Netherlands but this one's
very much inspired by one called the
Hoeven ring which is a bicycle bridge in
the shape of a circle around their very
busy interchange and fully felt that was
a fun idea to try and wanted to make
this look like a nice modern
a way to connect these neighborhoods
because one other really big issue with
the dog-bone interchange was that it was
such a major barrier between all of
these neighborhoods which I have on all
the sides of these routes of these roads
over here and at least I wanted to
connect them a little bit and felt the
best way to connect them or with one
bridge was do you have this bicycle
circle over here over the intersection
which really helps it look better but
also also function better in terms of
having these neighborhoods actually
connected and not feel so far apart from
each other and sort of blocked by this
major road which is going right through
it and it also provided some space since
the dog-bone interchange this took in a
lot of space so that was sort of cleared
up and it at least allows me to actually
have some appointment blocks over here
which I really wanted to have since
especially around the entrances of
cities you do quite commonly see that
you have some flat box and on the right
side over here I wanted to have some of
the older flat blocks since it is a
slightly older neighborhood with still
the odd red roof houses and on the left
side which is where the neighbor newer
neighborhood is I wanted to have some
flats which also helps that entire
neighborhood to have some more flat
blocks because I do feel it was lacking
in that respect here but yeah that's the
general plan for this area I might tense
it up a little bit more in the future in
the future especially alongside this
very new part of the neighborhood there
is still a large unused grassland
section over there which is just kind of
I'm not really happy about the way that
looks but I am generally very happy
about how this by scouring over here
turnouts and really want to use bicycle
breeches a bit more in the future since
and this is one major issue I can't
really get as much bicycle culture into
this city as you see in the Netherlands
and I have gotten a lot of feedback
about hey where are your bicycle lanes
and all your bicycling infrastructure
because it is this is the Netherlands so
you should have a lot of it but
realistically I just don't want to do
that since there owns one lane bicycle
lanes so it's just something we
I can't realistically get in because
most of the bicycle lanes in the
Netherlands are one-way and they go
around both sides of a road and I just
can't do that in the game since the
one-way bicycle lanes don't exist also
it's quite painful that they aren't red
it would be an amazing help if they were
red as well which is impossible because
it uses the same texture as the
sidewalks but yeah that's just wishful
thinking and the reason why I'm not
using bicycle infrastructure as much but
yeah that's about it for this episode
when it comes to the time-lapse part but
I do still have a flying camera point
which I really wanted to show the town
often
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]